[موسيقى]
نحييكم مشاهدينا وهذه التغطيه مستمره
للانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه سنتابع فيها
وبالتفاصيل كيف يبدو الامر في مختلف
الولايات مع شبكه مراسلين وسنناقش كذلك
مختلف الاسئله التي تطرح في هذه الاثناء
مع ضيوفنا اقبال كبير ومنافسه محتزمه مع
مواصله الامريكيين التصويت في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونغرس حيث حتى كل من
ترامب وبايدن انصرهما على ضروره الخروج
والتصويت بقوه في الانتخابات وسط توقعاته
باكتساح المنافسين الجمهوريين لها وبعد
ذلك
اليوم قد يستغرق انتظار نتائج ليله طويله
وربما اياما قبل ان يت اما اذا كان
الجمهوريون او الديمقراطيون هم من فازوا
وسيطروا على الكونغرس يتوقعوا كثيرون موجه
ضخمه من الدعم للحزب الجمهوري وضغطا كبيرا
من الرئيس السابق ترامب كذلك وهو ما يمكن
ان يؤدي الى اعلان الجمهوريين النصر بعد
ساعات من اغلاق صنادق الاقتراع ولكن عدته
ولايات رئيسيه مثل بنسلفانيا سبقت هذا
الامر بالاعلان عن ان فرز كل بطاقه
الاقتراع قد يستغرق ايامك
هناك مساله اخرى وهي التصويت عبر البريد
بعض الولايات تفرز صنادقها مبكرا قبل يوم
الانتخابات لقد يرجح حزب على اخر وبعض
ولايات اخرى قد لا تبدا العده الا في نفس
يوم الانتخابات لذا فرز وتحديد الاصوات
بالبريد هي عمليه قد تستغرق اياما
[موسيقى]
في نفس هذا السياق كان اذل رئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب بصوته في الانتخابات
النصفيه في ولايه فلوريدا وقال ترامب انه
على الناخبين الادلاء باصواتهم واكد ضروره
الابقاء على سياسه اغلاق الحدود وخفض
الضرائب واضاف ترامب ان الثلاثاء المقبل
سيحمل اخبارا مثيره كما قال دون تصريح
بعزمه الترشح للانتخابات المقبله
ولكن الاهم ان تصوطه انها انتخابات مهمه
جدا هو اتمنى ان يحدث الصواب اعتقد ان اول
شيء يجب التركيز عليه هو الجريمه هو تخفيض
الضرائب لدينا اكبر ضرائب في التاريخ
وسيواصل الديمقراطيون رفعها ويجب اغلاق
الحدود ولذلك اعتقد انه من المهم مواصله
اغلاق الحدود وتخفيض الضرائب اعتقد ان
الثلاثاء المقبل سيحمل اخبار مثيره وتطلع
لرؤيتكم في مراكو
ونبدا بالوقوف على الوضع الميداني مع شبكه
مراسلينا من بنسلفانيا بيار غانم ومان
جورجيا حسين الضوض اهلا بكم مع زملائي
الكرام الى هذه التغطيه وبالتوفيق في
مستقبل الساعات للوقوف على تفاصيل ما يحدث
ولكن اسمحوا لي ان نبدا من سلفانيا لنفهم
اكثر صوره بيير معك بيير هل هناك اقبال
كيف يبدو الاقبال وهل هناك معلومات اوليه
ترجح كافه عن اخرى في هذا التوقيت المبكر
نعلم
نتحدث اولا عن الاقبال كلنا في عاصمه
الولايه هاريس بورك قبل قليل الاقبال كان
مقبولا حتى الان لدينا اقله 25% من
المخترعين الذين جاءوا واوصلوا اصواتهم او
صوتوا من خلال البريد خرجنا من العاصمه
الى منطقه قريبه الى منطقه هيرشي ونحن
الان امام مكتبه عامه وفيها قلم اقتراع
يظهر هنا خلفي سالنا النسبه اعلى نحن
اصبحنا خارج المدينه وهذا ربما يكون مؤشر
جيد على انها الناس الذين
يؤيدون الجوريين بشكل عام هم اكثر حماسا
للتصويت وبالتالي نحن نشهد في هذا المركز
نسبه اقتراع اعلى من التي شهدناها في داخل
المدينه حيث يكون التصويت اكثر بالنسبه
للديمقراطيه بالنسبه لمؤشرات من هو متقدم
على الفريق الاخر الاشخاص هنا لم يتحدثوا
كثيرا عن هذا التفصيل ولكنه نعرف ان شبيرو
المرشح لمنصب الحاكم متقدم جدا على منافسه
مصريانو اما بالنسبه لمقاعد مجلس الشيوخ
فان الاستطلاعات كانت متقاربه جدا خلال
الايام الماضيه هناك عمليا ليس فرق بين
المرشح الديمقراطيه فترمان والمرشح
الجمهوري امام مدغشقر
طالما ذكرت مصر يعني
ونذاكر بانه كان من بين الحاضرين في احداث
الكابيتول في يناير 2020 هل هذا الموضوع
يعرقل يحفز همم يعيق طوله الى هذا المنصب
عندما تحدثت الى احد الناخبين قبل قليل
حول توزيع الاصوات ولماذا الفارق كبير جدا
بين المرشح الديمقراطي شافيرو لمركز
الحاكم ومستر يانو المرشح من قبل
الجمهوريين لم يكن لي شيء عن احداث
الكابيتول ما تحدث عنه هو ان مصريانه يمثل
عمليا اقصى اليمين لدى الجمهوريين وهذا ما
ابعد عنه حتى الجبوريين الوسطيين وهذا
يعطي
افضليه بالنسبه لشفيرو لانه هناك عدد من
الجمهوريين الذين ربما يصوتنا لمحمد اوز
في مجلس الشيوخ لانهم يرون انه في الوسط
ولكنهم يعتبرون ان المصري
جورج حسين اهلا بك معنا هل هناك نسبه
اقبال يمكن ان نصفها بالمهمه وكيف كذلك
يتفاعل الناخبون الامريكيون مع حمله
الاستقطاب ان تعبير التي يسلط البعض عليها
كل اضواء هذه الساعات الاخيره
تحيه لك ريم النسبه الاقبال ايضا هناك
كانت مقبوله الناخبون تحدثوا عن سهوله في
التصويت عمليه التصويت تكون سريعه يجب ان
نذكر هنا ان هذه العمليه العمليه التصويت
هذا العام هي الاولى همم في ظل قانون
الانتخابي الجديد في الولايه الذي يقول
منتقدون انه وضع عراقيل امام الناخبين
ووضع حواجاز ستؤثر بشكل كبير على الناخبين
لاسيما الناخبين من اصول افريقيه فيما
يقول المؤيدوه من الجمهوريين انه يسهل
عمليه تصويت لكن هو يمنع الغش في هذه
العمليه همم نتوقع طبعا كما قال لنا بعد
المسؤولين هنا ان تكون نسبه الاقبال ما
بعد الظهر اكثر مما هي مما كانت عليه في
الصباح نحن لاحظنا ان الناقبين الذين
يدخلون يخرجون بسرعه همم لانهم كما قالوا
هناك همم سهوله في عمليه التصويت ولكن
الاقبال بعد الظهر سيكون اكثر نسيمه بعد
انتهاء العدد من الموظفين من اع سيكون
هناك اقبال كما لاحظنا خلال تواجد هنا منذ
اسبوعين اثناء فتره التصويت المبكر كانت
بعد الظهر كان هناك ازدحام امام المراكز
الاقتراع طبعا الاختراع يختلف من مقاطعه
الى مقاطعه نحن الان امام مركز اقتراعي
كبير ضخم جدا لهذا ربما الان نشاهد ال-
ال- الناخبين خارج همم مكان التصويت ولكن
في مقاطعه اخرى يكون مركز التصويت صغير
لهذا نرى صفا خارج المبنى همم ايضا همم
دعينا نذكر ان هناك الان حديث عن
المستقلين هنا الذين قد يصوتون
لمرشحين مختلفين على منصبين مختلفين اي
يمكن لمصوت همم لناخذ مستقل ان يصوت
للجمهوريين على همم مجلس الشيوخ على مقر
مجلس الشيوخ ولكنه يصور لد ديمقراطيين على
مقعد او على منصب الحاكم والعكس صحيح
وهؤلاء المستقلون
يلعبون دورا كبيرا في تحديد النتائج التي
يحاول همم
المرشحات الاساسيات في همم على منصب او
على مقعد مجلس الشيوخ رافاييل ورناك عن
حزب الديمقراطي وهرش الواقع الحزب
الجمهوري ان يحسما النتيجه هذا اليوم لكي
يتجنب جوله اعاده همم الانتخابات في
ديسمبر المقبل يعني نقطه هذه التي ذكرتها
همم حسين كون بعض المستقلين
ساعتيننتخبون اشخاص ولن ينتخبوا احزاب
وهنا همم
ناتي لاطار ما يتحدث عنها البعض بانه ربما
هناك فتره تناقش ما بعد حسين انا اسمعك
ههه البعض يتحدث عن انه قد نخرج من اطار
الحزبين على كلن الى ان يعود الارسال
لزمينا احسان همم
جورج
هناك حديث اليوم مع هو مش اليوم حقيقه منذ
ايام انطلق عن هذه الثنائيه الحزبيه التي
نتبعها منذ سنوات في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعلم بانه هناك امكانيه او هناك
محاولات جرت لي انشاء حزب ثالث ولكن كان
هناك فشل هل هذه الانتخابات تؤشر الى
مفشلت يقول الباص قد تؤشر الى بدء ولاده
شكل جديد همم سياسي في امريكا
الشخصيه الوحيده القادره على انشاء حزب
ثالث في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
دونالد ترامب وهذا الرجل قرر انه سيبقى
جمهوريا وهو سوف يعلن عن قريب انه مرشح
لرئاسه الجمهوريه في عام 2024 وبالتالي
ليس موضوع طرح الحزب الثالث مساله مطروحه
في هذا الوقت النظام الانتخابي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يمنع الى حد
كبير جدا ان يكون هناك حزب الثالث والسبب
يعود الى انه في كل دائره انتخابيه يكون
هناك مليون
ناخب على مستوى مجلس النواب الامريكي
ويكون هناك مقعد واحد وبالتالي ليست هناك
امكانيه للاختيار من ثلاثه او اربعه او
خمسه اشخاص يجب ان يكون هناك شخص واحد
وبالتالي عندما تذهبين الى صندوق
الاقتراعين هو همم من المرشحين الافضل
والاقرب للوصول الى
وتصوتين جمهوري او ديمقراطي لان المرشح
الثالث او الرابع او المستقل او من حزب
الخضر ليس له حضور على الاطلاق في ان يصل
الى هذا المركز طيب عاد مجاشيد التواصل مع
حسين توضح حسين نحن نتحدث عن ولايات الشرق
والبعض يطرح كذلك اسئله بخصوص الانتخاب او
التصويت عبر البريد بعض الولايات اختارت
ان تبدا بفرز الاصوات قبل نهايه تصويت
اليوم البعض الاخر امتنعاه واراد ان تبدا
عمليه الفرز والتعداد مع اغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع هل توضح لنا اكثر هذه الصوره
هنا في ولايه جورجيا بدات عمليه التحقق من
التصويت المبكر قبل وقت ولد
لمحاوله منهم للحصول على نتائج في اسرع
وقت ممكن طبعا هي تختلف من الولايه لولايه
هكذا هي هذا هو الوضع في الولايات المتحده
لكل ولايه قوانينها هنا في جورجيا بدانا
بالفعل بالتحقق بنسبه للفرس هيبدا الفرز
اا اليوم بعد انتهاء الانتخابات ولكن
عمليه التحقق من دقه او صحه الاوراق همم
بدات همم كما ذكرنا كان هناك همم اقبال
كبير فيها تصويت المبكر همم اكثر من
مليونين و500,000 ناخذ عدله باصواتهم همم
بالحضور الشخصي او عبر البريد والاختراع
الغيابي همم البارحه فتحت سلطات جورجيا
تحقيق مع احدى المقاطعه بسبب عدم لسه لها
اكثر من 1,000 ورقه اقتراع غيابيه الى ال-
الناخبين وقالت همم او قال سكرتيره
الولايات بان ذلك غير مقبول لا سيما في ظل
التخوف من همم اتحجج او احتجاج همم تضرع
بعض الجمهوريين بان هناك عمليه تزوير لرفض
همم نتائج الانتخابات اذا لم تكن لصالحهم
همم ولكن بشكل عام اا الامور تسير على ما
يرام وايضا كان هناك بعض الشكاوى من همم
من بعد الناخبين الذين قالوا انه انهم تم
الطعن بتسجيلهم في همم اللوائح الانتخابيه
ولكن هذا الطعن تم حله عندما دخلت منظمات
تدافع عن الحقوق الناخبين هنا لتوضح ان
القانون الجديد ي- يجب ان ان يساعد النخب
على صوته طالما انه يمتلك همم اوراق
ثبوتيه طالما انه يلتزم بالقانون يجب ان
ان يساعد من قبل الموظفين في مكاتب
الاقتراع على الادلاء بصوته وعدت السبب في
رفض بعض الناخبين همم بانه سوء تواصل ما
بين همم موظفين في مكاتب الاختراع وما بين
السلطات المحليه بسبب حداثه القانون الذي
تم سنه الربيع الماضي هنا في جورجيا وضحت
الفكره حسين الطاوت من جورجيا واا كيار
غانم من سلفانيا شكرا جزيلا لكما والاكيد
سنعود لمتابعه كل هذه التفاصيل ولكن لاحقا
مشاهدينا نتابع دائما ما يحدث ونتابع
دائما كل هذه التفاصيل ان كانوا ضيوفنا
جاهزين طبعا لنفهم معهم ااا طلال الحاج
زميلنا طلال الحاج منه يورك ينضم لنا طلال
اهلا بك معنا حدثنا في نشرات سابقه عن
اقبال كبير في الواقع في نيويورك ولا يخفى
على احد بان منصب حاكم نيويورك يحظى
باهتماما وبمتابعه كبيره كيف هو المشهد من
عندك طلال
نعم الاقبال ما زال مستمرا اقف الان امام
مدرسه ثانويه هنا كارينا انه اصبح مركز
الاقتراع في واقع الامر والناس يتوافدون
عليه كنا قبل قليل في مكان اخر امام جمعيه
خيريه تسمى جمعيه فورد ومن الصباح من
الساعه 6:00 صباحا تقريبا والى الان
نتوافد هؤلاء الناس هناك اقبال كبير
لاهميه هذه الانتخابات في الواقع الامر
همم
25% من الناخبين الامريكيين يبعثوا لنا
باصواتهم بريديه
وحوالي مليون ونصف المليون قاموا بالتصويت
بسوره المبكره اي ان الفرز سيبدا في
الساعه التاسعه مساء لكل هذه الاصوات 25%
من الاصوات هناك ثلاثه عشر مليون و100,000
ناخذ في الولايه هذه همم ولذلك العدسه
يستغرق ببعض الوقت سواء للبريدي او او للم
ولناخبين همم اليوم همم النتائج لن تخرج
اليوم همم في غالب الامر ستتاخر بعض الشيء
ربما يوم يومين ربما ثلاثه حسب
سرعه الفرز نعم الصوره قادمه بالنسبه
للديمقراطيين كما تعرفين ان الحاجه حاكمه
الولايه مهدده بفقدان وظيفتها السيناتور
همم شوك شوبر وهو رئيس
الجمهقاتيه في مجلس الشيوخ مهدده وظيفته
ضد جوفانيا همم
ستتضح الصوره فيما بعد هذه هذه
بنتياز وهناك اربعه في الميه من المواطنين
لم يقرروا بعد في اي اتجاه يذهبوا ولكن
70% من سكان هذه الولايه
مقيدين
رسميا بانهم ديمقراطي
هذا اكيد ولكن كيف يبدو المشتركه كذ ك- في
واشنطن تنضم لناديه بلبيسي من واشنطن
ناديه اهلا بك معنا همم تبعنا كيف الواقع
وهناك نذكر مشاهدينا كذلك بان واشنطن كذلك
تغطي ما يحدث اما من خلال المراسلين او
كذلك من خلال السد جو في واشنطن الذي
يناقش مختلف تفاصيل ناديه كنت ناقشت مع
ضيوفك موضوع التموين هل لهذه الدرجه موضوع
التمويل مهم في هذه الانتخابات وهل فعلا
بانه في تاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لما همم تشهد عمليه التمويل هذا كانت
تشاهدتها في هذه المرحله
بالفعل ريم
16.7 مليار دولار كما ذكرتي كنت اتحدث مع
الضيوف على انه هذا المبلغ يمكن ان يمثل
ميزانيه لدوله باكملها من دول العالم
الثالث اذا اردتي فبالتالي الاموال التي
تصرف على هذه الحملات الانتخابيه غير
مسبوقه على الاطلاق في التاريخ الامريكي
وهذا يعطينا مؤشر على اهميه هذه
الانتخابات هذه الانتخابات التي ستتشكل
تركيباتها الجديده في شهر يناير وعلى فكره
حتى لو تم سيطره الجمهوريين على مجلس
النواب كما هو متوقع واحتمال بمجلس الشيوخ
لدى الرئيس شهران لتمرير بعض المشاريع اذا
استطاع لانه الكونجرس الجديد لن يتم همم
ربما حلف القسم الا في بدايه العام المقبل
وبالتالي هناك متسعه من الوقت لكن الجميع
يصرف اموالا طائله ملايين الدولارات تذهب
لدعم هذا المرشح او ذلك المرشح كل الهدف
منه هو عكس الاجنده الحزبيه كنت قد تحدثت
ايضا مع الزملاء كنت اريد ان اضيف نقطه
وهي ان هناك انتماء حزبي بمعنى يعني
الاشخاص المصنفين او المنتميين حسبيا سواء
جمهوريين ادوم ديمقراطين دوما يصوطون
لصالح المرشح التابع لهم حتى لو لم يكن
يعجبهم بمعنى لم يكن مؤهل بالشكل الكامل
لكن الذي يحدد هذه الانتخابات هو الناخب
المستقل او المتردد هناك مجموعه فكره كانت
تسمى برج
بمعنى بانه هناك طبقه من الحزب الديمقراطي
كان جميل للتصويت الى صالح الحزب الجمهوري
طبعا اتحدث عن انتخابات رئاسيه ليست
انتخابات نصفيه لكن يمكن هذه الانتخابات
ان تشهد بعض المفاجات الضيء ولكن الاموال
بالتحديد ستكون لها دور كبير في الاعلام
عن او اشهار هذا
المرشحينها بشكل
رهيب جدا خصوصا في الولايات ارجو حمل
لجورج عابدين
ساكتفي معكم بهذا نلتقي في نشرات اخرى
لمتابعه كل هذه التفاصيل همم زميلانا
ناديه بلبيسي من واشنطن وطلع للحاج من
نيويورك
ومشاهدينا قبل ان نذهب الى فاصل بعد قليل
مع اخر التطورات الانتخابات دعا رئيس
الامريكي جو بعيدا انصاره الديمقراطين الى
الاقتراع في الانتخابات التشديد النصفي
بايدينا شرى ايضا في تغريده نشرها على
حسابي في تويتر الى ان الديمقراطيين
قادرون كما قال على صنع التغيير في
الانتخابات الكونغرس
[موسيقى]
نتوقف الان مع فاصل قصير من بعضه نعود
لنناقش كل هذه النقاطات ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
وانا احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد هذه
الانتخابات هي استفتاء على ذلك الرجل
رغم انه او رغم انه قال انها ليست استفتاء
عليه بل استفتاء على الديمقراطيه في
امريكا ولكن في النهايه تبقى نتيجه
الانتخابات كاشفه لراي الامريكيين في
ادارته حتى الان المزيد مع طاهر بركاته
[موسيقى]
انا
الرئيس السادس والاربعون للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عمري 80 عاما قضيت منها 50 عاما
في السياسه ولم ازل
في عهد اصبحت فاتوره جره الغاز في مطابخ
المواطنين ولتر البنزين في سياراتهم
واضاءه غرف نومهم تقدم تماما كما يفعله
على الحقيبه النوويه واصبعيه على الزناد
في الخريف العمر الذي يصادف منتصف ولايه
الاولى اصل الى مكتب البيضاوي في الجناح
الغربي من البيت الابيض كل يوم لاجد كيف
راك ما طاقم ملفات البلاد الساخنه والعالم
الاكثر سخونه
وبعدما استكملت مواجهه كورونا وتداعيته
الاقتصاديه خفضت التضخم الذي لا يزال
مرتفعا واعدت البطاله الى مستويات ما
قبلنا واقريت مع الكونجرس قوانين ب 100
مليارات دولارات لكل منها كقانون رقائق
الالكترونيه والعلوم قانون المناخ والصحه
خطه تحفيز الاقتصاد وخطته اعاده بناء
البنيه التحتيه غير ان كثيرا من هذه
القوانين لما تاتي بعد ثمارا سريعه اقطفها
في انتخابات التجديد النصفيه التي تعكر
صفها قضايا الاجهاض والمخدرات والسلاح
المتفرد والنظام الصحي وتلك الجندريه هكذا
لك صحيح انني كبرت وقد اتعثر على سلم
طائره وهو ما يتوسله دونالد ترامب سبيلا
للهجوم الانتخابيه علي ولكني اظل الشغوفه
بقياده السيارات بسرعه جنونيه ولو كان في
شبابي صحيح انني كبرت وحصل ان اخطات مرارا
في خطابات ونسيت اسماء وخالفت مراسم
واختلطت علي امور وهو مابات الجمهوريون
يعيرونني به ايضا وانا ابن المؤسسه
التشريعيه العريقه والشهير بالخطابه
والفصاحه وسن القوانين رغم مشكله التلعثم
عندي صغار
يسار اليا عاده كفاني رئيس كاثوليكي بعد
جون كينيدي الذي اغتيل وكنائب رئيس لاول
رئيس اسود وكول رئيس تنوب عنهم امراه رغم
ما تسمعونه من اتهامات بمخالطات لصيقه
للنساء وبين ملف محلي اثره منه واخر دولي
يبقى عالقا تطفو على سطح ذاكرتي صور عائله
صغيره
زوجه الاولى ليليا وسوره ابنتي وهما
اللتان توفيت في حادث سير بعيدا انتخابي
في مجلس الشيوخ وصوره بوم وهو ابن الذي
خسر معركته مع السرطان عندما كنت نائما
للراس وسوره هانتر نجل الاخر المتورط
بسمعه سيئه والاتهامات فساد في اوكرانيا
انا جو بايدن
نعم سيكتب التاريخ عن عهدي انني تسببت
بفوضه في افغانستان عندما سحبته ايفاء لهم
بوعودي ولكنه سيكتب ايضا انني قتلت ايمن
الظواهري دون ان ارسل له جنديا واحدا على
الارض واوروبا العجوز مثلي والتي انحذر
شخصيا منها منقسمه وضعيفه رغم انني وقعت
على توسيع الناتو ليشمل فنلندا والسويد من
اجل حمايتها بين انني احكم في وقت يبزغ
فجر اقطاب عالميه رائده جديده عينها على
ما تعتبره انها القومي قد تبدا بروسيا في
اوكرانيا ولا تنتهي بالصيني
قوى الامر الواقع النوويه الشماليه او
الطامحه كائران والتي فشلت في اعادتها الى
الاتفاق النووي يقول للتاريخ ان هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه عاده ما تكون استفتاء
على الرئيس وماضيه ويقول للحاضر انها قد
تكون على الرئيس السابق ومستقبله السياسيه
اما مستقبل السياسي انا فربما لم يعد
جمبئني بالكثير انا
الرئيس الامريكي عن اوراق اختراع انتخابات
التسجيل النصفي خلال المره فون الجاري لكن
اسم جوبايدن لا يمكن فصله باي حاله عن
الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه وتحديدا الخاصه
بالكونجرس الامريكي
جلس على مقعده داخل مجلس الشيوخ اول مره
عام
1973 ولم يبراحه الا في عام 2008 عندما
انتقل الى البيت الابيض نائبا للرئيس
الاسبق باراك اوباما
اراد ان يسجل موقفا سريعا يظهره كشخصيه
الوطنيه
بعد ذلك
مناصب قياديه شغلها داخل الكونجرس لعلى
ابرزها رئاسه اللجنه القضائيه لمده 17
عاما ولا يزال قانون يعرف بجرائم بيض
يطارده حتى يومنا هذا حيث كان من كبار
المدافعين عن قانون الجرائم الفيدراليه
عام 1994
موبايل برزه في لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
لعب دورا في السياسه الخارجيه لمده 11
عاما وكثيرا ما يتباهى بانجازاته في
الخارج حتى انه قدم قائمه الى واشنطن بوست
بعد اختياره نائبا لاوباما تظهر لقاءاته
مع 150 زعيما من حوالي 60 دوله ومنظمه
دوليه ما جعل نقادا يصفون الامر بالمبالغه
مقللين من فتنه في السياسه الخارجيه
سياسته داخل الكونغرس كثيره ما وصفت
بالازدواجيه بينما كان يدعم الجهود
الانسانيه في الخارج كان يدفع ايضا باتجاه
العمليات العسكريه في التسعينات تدخل
العسكري الامريكي
في تحرير الكويت عام
1991 وان كان من بين من صوته لصالح غزوه
افغانستان عام 2001
صوت ايضا لصالح الحرب العراق في عام 2002
35 عاما قضاها بيض بين اروقه الكونجرس
[موسيقى]
قابله 10 اعوام مجموع خبرته في البيت
الابيض لعل خبرته في المجال التشريعي
جعلته يقدر الان مدى تاثير التجديد النصفي
على منصبه فهو يدركه انها بمثابه استفتاء
شعبي على فتره الرئاسته
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من
واشنطن الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه تحسين عبد الحسين اهلا بك من
واشنطن كذلك وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا بكمين اسم حالي
ان ابدا مع الاستاذ حسين في الواقع البعض
يضع نقاط استفهام حول ما همم سمي
بالاستقطاب هناك عمليه استقطاب قسوه
تعيشها الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه هل
هذا في صالح الثنائيه الحزبيه هل هذا في
صالح الانتخابات الامريكيه تعتقد
اعتقد ان هو حتما في صالح الانتخابات كل
ديمقراطيه بحاجه الى ارتفاع نسبه التصويت
لانه هذا يساهم في المصادقه على
الانتخابات نفسها لا اعتقد انه الانقسام
اكثر من الماضي كل الانتخابات الماضيه
التي عشناها كان الانقسام حاده والاستقطاب
حاد بين الطرفين اعتقد ان المشكله الوحيده
التي تواجهها الولايات المتحده اليوم هي
امكانيه ان لا يقبل بعض المرشحين
المهزومين بنتائج الانتخابات وهذا ما
سيظهر في الساعات ال 48 المقبله دكتور
وليد همم هناك كذلك همم حديث عن ان
المستقلين قد يحدث هنا تغيرا همم ولو
طفيفا في نتائج هذه الانتخابات حتى انا
منذ قليل زميل جورج يقول لنا بانه بعض
المستقلين ربما سينتخبون ديمقراطيه يعني
مجلس النواب جمهوريه مجلسها شويه وكان
التصويت ولي
حزبي ما الذي يمكن او كيف يمكن ان يؤثر
ذلك على الوجه السياسي العام الامريكي
اجمالا المستقلون يعني المستقلون يختارون
من يشاؤون للمقاعد خاصه وان هذه
الانتخابات هي لكل اعضاء او معظم اعضاء
الكونغرس في ذلك قد يظن انه الديمقراطي في
مجلس النواب هو افضل من خصمهم الجمهوري
والعكس صحيح في مجلس الشيوخ هذه ظاهره
قديمه ولكنها تؤثر فقط على من هم في الوسط
اي المستقلين بينما الجمهوريين
وديمقراطيين بشكل عام يتبعون خط الحزب ههه
هل هذا يضعنا في اطار ما كنا نتحدث عن
انقسامات همم يعني مهمه تعيشها هذه
الاحزاب هناك من يقول بان هذه الاحزاب هي
نفسها تتاكل في داخل همم
فهل هذا التصويت ربما يمكن ان يجعل من
بقاء هذه الاحزاب همم تتلاشى شيء هذا ممكن
ممكن جدا اعتقد اصلا انه هذه الاحزاب هي
ليست يعني احزاب واضحه المعالم انه لو
نظرنا الى الديمقراطين لراينا ان هناك فرع
يعني معتدل بقياده بعضنا لا لان راينا انه
هناك فرع ينتمي لليسار اقصى اليسار بقياده
تونس اندرس وكذلك الامر في الحزب الجمهوري
هناك معتدلين وسطيين او وسط يمين الوسط
وهناك من يقودهم الرئيس السابق ترامب وهو
الى اقصى اليمين في همم يعني همم في
الانتخابات نرى انه هناك نوع من التلاحم
ولكنه تلاحم مصطنع وليس بعيد المدى اعتقد
بسبب كبر حجم الولايات المتحده ينظر ان
نرى اكثر من حزبين ولكن داخل كل من هذين
الحزبين اعتقد ان هناك احزاب كثيره متعدده
ومتنوعه طبعا تفضلتم بالحديث عن المستقلين
وهو لا غالبا ما يشكلون الترجيح بين
الحزبين في عدد كبير من الولايات همم
دكتور فارس ترامب وان لم يكن حاضر ك ايه
مرشح ولكن ضل ترامب يخيم على هذه
الانتخابات وتصريحات حتى يتبعها البعض بكل
اهتمام ترامب يتحدث عن الاقتصاد ويقول
اانتخبوا الجمهوريين فلا اقتصاد معنا بعض
في المقابل يقول بانه ان لم تنتخبوا
الديمقراطيين فانكم ستشاركون فضلا خلال
الديمقراطيه داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه الثنائيه هل تنفع هل تضر
كيف هو كذلك تاثير بعيدا على هذه
الانتخابات ولو كان بعيدا
اولا الثنائيه هي نظام امريكا ما لم تكن
هنالك ثنائيه يجب ان يكون نظاما اخر كما
في فرنسا هنالك عدت احزاب وتنتهي العمليه
في كتلتين اساسيتين في الجوله الاخيره هذا
النظام هو النظام الفرنسي في بريطانيا
الكتل البرلمانيه هنا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حزب عين مظلاتين في الحقيقه
البعض يقول بما تكون اربع احزابري اذا
حللنا كل حزب جمهوري والديمقراطي وبعض
الاحزاب الوسطى المستقلين اجمالا هم كتله
ليس لديهم احزان ولكن فيما يتعلق بهذه
الانتخابات يعني القائمه الان همم الطرفان
ترامب من ناحيه من الناحيه اخرى قد بدا
بخوض هذه المعركه منذ بدايه هذا العام
يعني انا بتقديري لن تؤثر تصريحهم
التعبويه على الناخبين لكي يغيروا رايهم
ولكن قد تؤثر بمكان واحد على تشجيعهم
للذهاب والانتخاب بشكل عام اخر اسبوع واخر
ثلاثه ايام وربما الساعات التي تسبق يوم
الانتخاب هذه الساعات تعبئه الانصار وليست
اقناع الاخرين بتقديره كيف ترى الموضوع
همم دكتور حسين هل فعلا يمكن فصل الاشخاص
عن هذه العمليه الانتخابيه لان بعض
المراقبين كذلك همم يقولون بانه وكانها
انتخابات على الاشخاص يعني هناك مجموعه
تريد ان تدعم وفي المقابل مجموعه اخرى
تريد ان تبطل مشروع ترامب هل يمكن رؤيه
المشهد بهذه الطريقه او هناك مبالغه في
القول ذلك
لحد من هي انتخابات حال الاشخاص خصوصا
النظرنا الا انه يعني معظم الدوائر في
مجلس النواب هي دوائر صغيره يعني دوائر
داخل كل ولايه
والقول الامريكي المعروف اوبالتك صارلوك
البالتيكس كل السياسات هي سياسات محليه
فلذلك نرى انه كل من الحزبين يتراخى عندما
يخرج اي من المرشحين باسمه يخرج عن
الرساله الاساسيه للحزب اعتقد انه نرى
الاداره المركزيه في كل من الحزبين تتراخى
وتسمح بهذا النوع من الخروج عن الرساله
لانها تعتبر انه المرشح هو ابن يعني
الدائره التي او بنت الدائره التي تخوض
فيها الانتخابات وهمم اهل مكه ادرى
بشعارها لذلك اعتقد انه الشخصيات تلعب
دورا كبيرا يعني حتى لو كان هناك رساله
معينه ولكن في الغالب الكاريزما الشخصيه
همم معرفه همم اط ناخذ اعتقد انها كلها
هذه تلعب ادوار كبيره في تحديد الرابح
والخاسر في هذه الانتخابات دكتور فارس
الانتخابات النصفيه التي لا تتزامن مع
الانتخابات الرئاسيه تكون لها اهميه خاصه
وهذه الانتخابات لها اهميه خاصه ومضاعفه
كذلك بنظر الى انتخابات المرتقبه في 2420
كيف لهذا الانتخابات ان تؤثر على انتخابات
قادمه منتظره وبالغت الاهميه
احيانا انتخابات مصر
تكون يعني نوع من داخل للانتخابات
الرئاسيه كما حصل كما كاد ان يحصل في عام
2010 عندما كان الرئيس اوباما يواجه خساره
في الكونجرس 2010 وجاء حزب الشاي الى ما
هنالك ولكنه على الرغم من ذلك انتصر في
2012 بينما الرئيس الذي خسر الانتخابات
النصفيه 2018 خسر ايضا الانتخابات
الرئاسيه حسب الموجه الان ما يجري في هذه
الانتخابات بتقديره انه هنالك موجع عميقه
من الناخبين المحافظين الذين ينتقدون
ايتاء الاداره البعض يقول انه ترامب
يعبئهم البعض الاخر يقول لا ترامب يستعمل
هذه الموجه فهو لا يخلق الموجه هنا ما
يدري كيف يحسن كيف يستعمله وبالتالي قد
تكون له حدود المشكله مع الرئيس السابق
ترامب هي المسائل الاداريه التي سوف
يواجهها
الان بعد غدا ويوم الانتخابات وليس همم
الحاله الشعبيه لا هو حاله شعبيه قويه
ولكن له مشاكل اداريه وقانونيه كثيره بنفس
الوقت وانت راي شخصي كيف ترى دكتور فارس
هل همم ان الديمقراطيين همم لم يكن لهم
حضور يقنع ان خبطله همم سنوات الماضيه
سنتين الماضيه عين على الاقل
اذا نظرت الى السبب الاساسي وهو تقريبا
معترف به من قبل القياده الحزب الديمقراطي
شخصيه الرئيس يعني فارق كبير ان يكون من
يقول الحزب الديمقراطي اوباما بقدرته
التعبويه على افكار بسيطه
والرئيس بايد ان الذي باعتراف القياده
الديمقراطيه ربما كان الافضل لكي يختاروه
ما بين رؤساء او قيادات كثيره في العام
2020 لمواجهه ترامب ولكن يبدو ك- كسعيم
للتيار الديمقراطي او الحزب الديمقراطيه
لم ينجح في اقناع اكبر قاعده شعبيه
بالوقوف معه على الاقل في هذه الانتخابات
دكتور حسين الى اي مدى ناخذ الامريكي
يلتقط مثل هكذا تفاصيل ويبني عليها همم
رايه وبالتالي همم
ام ان هناك قضايا اخرى تهمه اكثر من هذه
الشخصيات اكثر من بعض واكثر من سيتولى
قياده الولايات المتحده اتركيه قادمه
نتحدث على قضايا مثل همم
المعيشه مثل التطبيب مثل الهجره همم وعديد
من القضايا التي اتبعناها والتي ربما تمثل
اولويه لدينا قبل امريكيه
لا تقدر
كل التفاصيل اولا كما تحدثنا المواضيع
المحليه هي اكثر ما يهمه ما يهمها هؤلاء
الناخبين مثلا لو نظرنا الانتخابات ولايه
فرجينيا التي تغلب فيها الجمهوريون على
الديمقراطيين راينا انه كان الموضوع
يتمحور حول المناهج المدرسيه ولا يتعلق
باي شيء يرتبط بالاقتصاد او بالامور
الكبرى لذلك اعتقد انه السياسه المحليه
تلعب حيزا تلعب حيز كبير ولكن في نفس
الوقت يعني همم يحاول كل من الحسبين همم
الافاده من مما يجري طبعا يعني الكل اليوم
يتحدث عن التضخم ولكن الاقتصاد الامريكي
هو الوحيد الذي ينمو في اقتصادات الدول
الكبرى في العالم
والبطاله في ادنى المستويات اذا من يحاول
تحليل بالاشاره الى الاقتصاد لا اعتقد انه
تحليل موفق ولكن على الرغم من ذلك نجح
جمهوريون في الافاده من هذا الموضوع وهم
طبعا انا اعتقد انه الجمهوريون تتجهون
باتجاه الفوز لانه نعرف انه تاريخيا همم
في الولايه الاولى لاير رئيس الانتخابات
النصفيه عاده ما تكون ضده ويخسرها وهذا
حصل لجميع باستثناء طبعا جورج بوش الابن
في ولايه الاولى لذلك انا لا اعتقد ان
الناخب الامريكي يدقق كثيرا اعتقد ان هناك
شعور هناك يعني انتماء حسبي وقابلي في
اغلب الاحيان بالطبع باستثناء المستقلين
الذين يدققونا عاده اكثر من الاخرين دكتور
فارس نحن لا طالما تحدثنا عن التصويت
الجمهوريين او التصويت التيمقراطين ولكن
هناك كذلك فرضيه اخرى وهي ان يكون المشهد
همم معرقل لعمل الكونجرس ان تكون التشكيله
الحسابيه معاقله لعمل الكونجرس يعني ليس
كونجرس يمكن ان يخدم الرئيس الحالي ويدعمه
ولك كونجرس يمكن ان يعطل هل همم طرح ثالث
لشكل ثالث يمكن ان ينشا عن هذه انتخابات
تعتقد
السيناريوهان الاساسيان هنالك ربما
السناريو الثالث الذي رايناه هو الكونجرس
الذي يتمرد على الرئيس ترامب ويحاول
العزله هذه ظاهره استثنائيه في العهد
الماضي في هذا العهد في هذه المره هنالك
سيناريوهان الاول هو ان ينتصر
الديمقراطيين في الهيئتين وبالتالي لن
تكون هنالك مشكله لبيضن في السنتين
القادمهتان التقدير العام انه ذلك الان
يحدث الذي ممكن ان يحدث حسب العمليه
الرقميه الان وسنرى في نهايه النهار بدايه
الليله او حتى غدا صباحا انه الجمهوريون
سوف يسيطرون على مجلس النواب بتقدير انا
المعركه فعلا ستكون على مجلس الشيوخرا
مجلس الشيوخ همم ليس هناك اعتقاد انه اي
من الحزبين اذا انتصر سوف ينتصر باعداد
كبيره اما اثنين من هذا الناحيه اثنين من
الناحيه الاخرى لا نعرف اذا كان دور نائب
الرئيس سوف يكون الحاسم كما هو الان اذا
تم سيطره الحزب الجمهوري على اله عندها
انا براي هذه المره التعطيل سوف يكون اكبر
من الماضي لانه هي رد سيكون لهم رده فعل
اقوى على الحزب الديمقراطي وعلى اداره بيض
وسنرى لجان تحقيق يعني كل ما فعلوه
بالترامب سوف يحاول الجمهوريون ان يفعلوه
ببيض وهذا يعني سنتين القادمه ستكون سنوات
ازمات سياسيه ايضا اكثر من الازمات ال-
سيبقى هي اساسا كانت هناك ازمات سابقه
ولكن حضرتك ترجح بان يكون مجلس النواب
للجمهوريين هكذا فهمت من حضرتك صحيح بحسب
قراءتك هكذا انا هكذا انا اكثر من قراءه
هي قراءه باتت همم اكثريه الخبراء بما
فيهم همم الذين يهتمون بالموضوع داخل
الحزب الديمقراطي السؤال ليس اذا سياخذ
الجمهوريون او او لا ما هو الفرق يعني اذا
كان الفارق خمسه اصوات تقريبا متوازن ولكن
تكلمنا عن 28 صوت 30 صوت اما يعتبر البعض
يعني بيكون هنالك حسن كبير هذا يدفع
للتفاوض مع الحزب الجمهوري دكتور حسين ما
رايك في هذه النقطه
طبعا الفارق حاليا دقيق اصلا هو خمس مقاعد
حتى تحوز يعني حتى ياخذ الجمهوريون
الغالبيه في النواب وهو يعني مناصفه في
مسجد شيوخ يمكن الذهاب اي من النتائج ممكن
طبعا الكل يتحدث عن عن موجه حمراء وانا
رايت تقارير متعدده تشير الى انه قد تكون
قد تكون الحديث عن الموجه الحمراء مبكرا
انه على الاقل التصويت الممكن يظهر تفوق
ديمقراطي واسع انه قد تكون القاعده
الديمقراطيه متحفزه اكثر مما يعني تشير
الى استطلاعات الراي لذلك
لا يعود الى همم ان الديمقراطينهم من يصون
عبر البريد اكثر فبالتالي تكون ربما
الاعداد الاوليه اكثر في مرحله اولى
صحيح هم عاده ما يصوطون اكثر ولكن مقارنه
هذه المره الفارق هذه المره مع جمهوريين
بالفارق في العام 20 والفرق في العام 18
يبدا ان هذه المره الفرق اكبر بكثير طبعا
هذه فقط يعني نقطه واحده ولا يمكن التعويل
عليها ولكن يبدو ان هناك مؤشرات انه قد لا
تكون دقيقه وقد تحصل مفاجاه كما حصلت
مفاجاه ترامب في العام 2016
في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
والتغطيه دائما مستمره ومشاهدين على قناه
العربيه بشبكه مراسلينا كذلك من مختلف
الولايات لمتابعه اولا فتره التصويت وفيما
بعد كذلك سيتم فتح صناديق الاقتراعه
والبدء بالفارس ربما في ساعات متاخره من
هذا الليل او كذلك بعد ايام يقول الباص
يتم تقديم نسب النهائيه لهذه المشاركات
كذلك الساعات متتاليه على قناه العربيه
سنتابع معكم بنقاشاتنا وتحليلنا ما يحدث
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نتحدث
مشاهدينا عن الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
لهذه السنه هذه انتخابات كل سنتين وطبعا
همم لهذه الانتخابات اهميه كبيره خاصه
وانها انتهاء انتخابات لا تاتي في نفس
توقيت الانتخابات الرئاسيه وبالتالي هي
تحمل اهميه القصوى واهميتها سنه تبعها ولا
كفي نشراتنا القادمه السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]